We said earlier that the cost to make 92 glasses wiper sets is going to depend
on the cost to make one wiper set, which is choice a, and also the number of
wiper sets total that are made, choice c. So, I know that a and c are going to
be the letters that go in these boxes, but I need to think about the operator
that I want between them before I can decide which one goes in the first box and
which one in the second. Or, if that order matters at all. In previous lessons,
we thought about how total money spent is equal to the money spent per unit
times the number of units that are being made. So, if we want to make two
glasses wipers instead of one, we're going to pay twice as much money. If you
wanted to make three wipers sets, we're going to spend three times as much
money, and so on and so forth. So, we need to multiply these two quantities, a
and c, together. I'm going to go ahead and fill in a multiplication sign in this
box. We learned earlier from the commutative property of multiplication that
when we're multiplying two things together, order doesn't matter. So, it doesn't
matter if I have a or c in this box, or a or c in this box. As long as I have
one in one spot and one in the other, we are good to go.